[Music]
your show is so popular and what's
unusual it becomes more and more popular
every year it seems to be really
wonderful everything yes we have really
really wonderful fans we always have
it's true you can tell a lot of your
fans are here today I was hoping and
honestly because I was hoping if this is
okay with you I did have a night we tape
like two doors down is that what we are
from yeah you take very close to this
yeah possible I would love to take one
of these people over to the set I would
like to get a souvenir from the set that
you came have give them a set from the
venire yes yeah souvenir for souvenir
from the set I said that back we'll
learn how yes that's fine with you know
that we have no time for that okay
they're really mad right Jerry
Bohdan canceled Christmas yeah we're not
going to do that instead I'm going to
read my poem I think that sounds really
fun okay and and and in fact we have a
cart outside I could drive over there if
you're gonna ride you want to do it
[Applause]
I'm Judy you're Judy my mother's name is
Judy yes well with Parsons never mind
it's nice to meet you would you like to
go yes really want to go right now yeah
we're gonna go right now you have to go
yeah I be let's do it
[Applause]
okay here we go we're going this way
this way back in for it's very cold back
audiences on this side the audience is
right there get your Barry
have you been walking Oh are you lying
no I know I don't think you don't love
it I'm saying to discover you can't let
you sit up front yeah I'll Drive yeah
okay twist awkwardly and talk to you
both this way okay look at that all
right here we go you're ready to go yes
all right now hold you in no seatbelts
do you find that no I do very well yeah
oh this is fantastic look what a pretty
if there are you doing by the way
Sammy bro where San Gabriel Gabriel
Gabriel yeah that's fantastic
are you visiting LA right now are you
just going back home tonight
yeah I'm visiting LA cuz I live in
Westminster okay are they with you right
now no oh we left her all right this is
the door this there we go I walk in
every day this is the door not everybody
does I like this side doors are set
beyond there that's where our audience
will sit this is beautiful today
no this is much nicer than like the
camera alley where all the cameras will
be the audience's over there and we tape
over here and if you want to let's go to
the apartment we're gonna get you a
souvenir some sort of souvenir from this
set that's big however that's Simon
Helberg and he's real
[Applause]
a souvenir from sunset I have to be
frank with you I feel a little awkward
taking anything directly from the set
that we might want to use if you don't
mind we'll take this instead
[Applause]
thank you very much yeah all right if
you have real beer in the frigerator
we'll need that replay it's mine now
good luck with that yeah on eBay The Big
Bang Theory airs Thursdays at 8 on CBS
and Monday through Thursday on TBS Jim
Parsons and Simon Helberg and Judy
[Applause]